[Music]
listen i'm gonna need your help with
something
is it about money no then i'm your gal
what's up
george is up for a coaching job at the
university of tulsa
telsa oh last year
i lost 800 on that damn team sir to hear
that
you know i'm fine with most of the
division one stuff but
these independent teams i i just can't
seem to get a handle on it you think if
george got that job he might give me an
inside line
oh well i'd cut him in make it look like
a christmas present
would you please listen to me if we move
up there
other than holidays you're not gonna see
your grandkids
well that's a point you make it sound
like a
sophie's choice kind of deal during
dinner
maybe you could express how devastating
it would be
to be away from the kids well i don't
think i use the word devastating
that doesn't sound like me okay well use
whatever word you want
i might use heartbroken
good use that yeah maybe you got a
thesaurus
[Music]
you're making a sandwich i'm a creature
of habit
hey why don't we all go around the table
and
say what we're thankful for come on
really
yes really i'll start
i'm thankful to be surrounded by my
loving family
what about that guy that guy dr sturgis
is part of our extended family okay and
i'm also
thankful for this warm and comfy home
that god has blessed us with
and this great neighborhood with my mom
living right across the street
and of course our excellent school
system
that provides our children with a
world-class education
missy i'm thankful that there's two
different ghostbuster cartoons
that's it unless you know about a third
one
okay my turn um
i am so thankful to be able to watch my
grandchildren grow up
and i can't even tell you how much it
means to me
that y'all live right across the street
and if you all weren't
i would just be heartbroken
and not just heartbroken crestfallen
and chagrined
and uh i'm also thankful for my health
that that mole of my hip turned out to
be
nothing and i'm very thankful for john
here
who has brought so much happiness to me
that's it for me well it doesn't matter
because you obviously went to your
mother
and made her your stocking horse of
course she went to me
moved to oklahoma what's wrong with you
wait we're moving to oklahoma
i thought texans don't like oklahoma
you're damn right we don't what's wrong
with oklahoma i'll tell you later okay
that's enough of this nobody's moving
anywhere let's just have a nice
quiet dinner that's it you're you're
gonna make the decision for me
i'm making a decision for us all right
then
where are you going george george
as we set in silence i had a horrible
realization
for the first time in my life i didn't
look forward to doing my homework
just watch the tv
[Music]
you